[Musique]
du battant des lames au sommet des
montagnes
l'aménagement du quartier des colis
mation est le fruit d'une histoire
commune
ainsi la dixième résidence d'artistes du
département consacre son oeuvre à
l'histoire de ce lieu on remercie aussi
tous nos témoins qui ont participé avec
franchise et honnêteté à notre démarche
et j'espère qu'ils se retrouveront en
partie travail le récit ne connaît plus
donc comme on a plein de tableau et
plein de personnages on considère que
c'est plus une fresque eastbourne
historique que un vrai récit historique
alors on raconte enfin compte tout
simplement 170 ans d'histoire du
lieu-dit colimaçon que ce soit le
domaine agricole
mais tout simplement parce que quand on
parle du domaine on parle du quartier
quand on parle du cartillon parle de
l'ancien domaine qui est devenue
maintenant jardin botanique mascara donc
le lien entre eux enfin compte ce
premier domaine agricole gros domaine
agricole de créer par ce stand de
chateauvieux avec la famille tunnel pour
arriver enfin compte en 2021 au jardin
bio voilà au jardin botanique de
mascarin les tableaux de cette fresque
botan historique s'enchaînent dans ce
cadre enchanteur
ainsi chaque coin du jardin devient une
scène de vie fruit des témoignages et
des recherches historiques et
scientifiques de compétence du
département à ses la culture ça c'est là
l'un 10e riz 10 nantes et ratier nous
avons fait sur plusieurs sites
mais sur sip ce site cela s'est vraiment
en cohérence avec la nature et puis une
pièce de théâtre qui retrace l'histoire
d'un domaine réunionnais un domaine
départemental et ben c'est toujours
enrichissant
plusieurs représentations sont prévues à
mascara jardin botanique afin de
permettre la conservation d'une partie
de notre histoire
[Musique]